kylie jenner's so sick she's in the
hospital it was so scary the 22 year old
beauty mogul announced that she's been
under the weather so much so that she's
cancelled a major appearance at Paris
Fashion Week next week because of it
Kylie shared the news on Twitter
Wednesday telling her fans said she's
heartbroken to be missing the ball ma
show the event is extra special to Kylie
because she recently teamed up with
Beaumont creative director Olivier for a
new makeup collab I'm having so much fun
I feel like I'm getting into so many
cool Beauty things I'm excited about it
quote unfortunately I'm really sick and
unable to travel I'm heartbroken to be
missing the show but I know that my
amazing team and my friends who are in
town for the event will help me be there
in spirit et has confirmed that kylie is
in the hospital but she's said to be
doing well under doctor's care the
reality star was also a no-show at the
Emmys on Sunday after she was scheduled
to present the award for outstanding
competition program with her sisters Kim
and Kendall from Keeping Up with the
Kardashians Kim kardashian-west
a source told et at the time that she
missed out on the gig because she was
sick her sisters did however still
manage to create a stir when the
audience appeared to laugh at them our
family knows firsthand how truly
compelling television comes from real
people just being themselves telling
their stories unfiltered and unscripted
here are the nominees for outstanding
competition series what are they
laughing at them they were in the
audience then and let me tell you what
the Kardashians do because I used to
live next door to Kim and Kanye and I
talked about it in my film what they do
is they get laughed at and then they go
home and they count their money and they
print it I think they have a printing
machine so they weren't really stressed
about the laughter but honey the last
thing they care about they're like this
ching ching ching and the mom is like
landing ten we're bringing the deals so
you know